And when most people talk about inflation, they're talking about price inflation.
And that's just the general increase in the level of prices for goods and services.
And you probably have a sense of that,...
...that every year, in kind of a normal economy,...
...things seem to get a little bit more expensive, although not everything does.
But especially if you look at something like health care or the cost of education,...
...you definitely see things getting more expensive every year.
But one interesting question is, "How do you measure it?"
How do you measure inflation?
And what the Bureau of Labor Statistics does...
...and this is actually the most used measure of inflation.
They create something called the "Consumer Price Index".
And the way they do it is that they define a basket of goods.
And actually, a basket of goods and services.
So, what they do is they go and look at the average urban consumer,...
...and they say, "What do they need in their life?" They might need some housing.
They might need some fuel, some natural gas for their home.
They need gasoline for their cars.
They needed energy in other ways.
They might need some type of services.
They might need transportation.
And they try to come up with a basket of all the things...
...that the average consumer in an urban environment might need.
And they figure out how much that would cost them in Year one.
And let's say that in Year one that it cost them a hundred dollars.
The actual basket that the CPI constructs would not cost a hundred dollars.
But I'm gonna do this for the sake of simplicity.
And they'll weigh these based on how much, what percentage...
...they think people spent on housing versus fuel versus services...
...versus transportation.